what up space fam goes in here from
anime up we're back at it again to
discuss yet another demon slayer
character in my last video about how
strong is shinobu i said i'd do another
if we reached 5500 likes on that one and
we're well over 8 200 likes right now so
here we are with a much requested video
about genya shina zugawa aka wind
hashirasanami's little brother aka the
fifth and last slayer who passed the
final selection exam with tanjiro that i
have yet to cover as usual to unlock the
next how strong is demonstrator video
channel the slayer within and smash that
like button with no mercy remember that
smashing that like button is your ichi
energy and passing is moves on energy so
choose wisely if we can hit 6500 likes i
repeat 6 500 on this video i'll get
started on the next one asap just let me
know who you want me to cover next
whether it's upper moon 2 or upper moon
1 or someone else entirely that i
haven't covered yet or if you have
another video you are burning up to see
let me know what it is in the comments
if you haven't yet make this the video
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates that's
just the way it works and while you wait
for your requested video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all the demon moons all the
hashira at least 18 other how strong his
videos about demonstrator characters and
much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all
like his older brother the 16 year old
genya does not make a good first
impression the story focuses on him at
first along with khan now and zenith at
the beginning of the final selection
foreshadowing his future importance but
like zainto and kano we can't really
tell much about him from this first
glance so let's fast forward to the end
of the final selection exam he is by far
the most irritated and rude graduate
albeit inosuke wasn't present genya asks
for his katana and the ubuyashiki
sisters kiria and kanata tell him and
the others that they will first be
provided with their core uniforms and
then they will each choose the ore for
their future sword it will take up to
two weeks for their swords to be
finished the graduates are then given
crows and a sparrow for zenitsu but the
irritated and angry genya shoes away his
crow repeating again that he doesn't
care about crows he wants his katana now
he wants the color changing nichiren
blade right now he says this as he's
pulling the hair of kanata who mind you
is five years old so genya just seems
like a horrible person here and tundra
has to step in and break genya's arm
until he lets go so now let's fast
forward to chapter 105 where we'll start
to see what kenya is truly capable of in
this chapter genya tells tundra they are
not friends because he broke his arm but
tundra replies that was necessary genya
was completely in the wrong for hitting
a girl tunjiro is the guy trying to
befriend him while kenya is very
standoffish and gets upset when tundra
uses his first name as if they were
close it is at this point that tundra
notices that one of genya's front teeth
that was missing no longer is missing
this is a clue as to get his true powers
which we are about to see soon genya
joins tanjuro in the fight against upper
moon for hantengu it is at this point
that we start to see just how unique
genya is compared to other demon slayers
besides being able to regrow teeth
despite his eagerness to get a katana he
actually pulls out a double-barreled
shotgun at first and fires it at the
upper moon for clones the shotgun
bullets actually help decapitate two of
them but unfortunately that's not enough
to defeat these clones tundra does smell
the gun and bullets and notices they
smell like a nichiren blade and that's
because they're made of the same
material as the blades meaning genya can
kill normal demons without using a blade
he just has to shoot their head off
which is pretty unique and cool he does
have a short nichiren blade though and
he pulls it out to try to finish one of
the clones but as tangero points out
every time you cut one of the clones
they just divide with these demon clones
their heads are not their weak spots
genya then gets impaled and it's
definitely a wound that might have
spelled the end for another slayer but
not for genya in fact kenya grabs hold
of the spear so the upper moon 4 clone
can't pull it out and then shoots it in
the head blowing it off very cool move
from genya i must say against a normal
demon genya would have won long ago but
these clones make up upper moon 4 after
all so they regenerate without issue as
one clone named izetsu pulls the spear
out they're surprised to see genya
quickly move behind him and as he's
about to slice off the head again with
his short katana saying he'll cut off
the head as many times as it takes he
gets electrocuted by another clone
called sekido sekido is shocked upon
initially unintended but appreciated by
the fact that genya isn't dying after he
received so many killing blows izatsu
also asks kenya how he's still alive and
what is he but genya simply stares him
down introducing himself as genya
shinozugawa the man who's going to kill
him he stands there looking crazy with a
shotgun in one hand and the katana in
the other it really doesn't get much
cooler than this later tangero sees
genya looking absolutely demonic with
fangs black eyes and the works
additionally he's unharmed having
recovered from all those fatal injuries
he's managed to pin aizetsu's body to a
tree using his own spear and now he's
just holding his detached head he then
grabs tundra by the throat insisting
that he genya is going to be the one to
slay the upper moon he wants to do so
and become a hashira he thinks tundra
will try to compete with him or
something like that but tundra is
totally cool with it and even says
hinesko will support him and his goal
with all their strength once again
tanjo's insane level of kindness leaves
yet another angry person dumbfounded
with tundra and nezuko's help eventually
genya runs into the small real body of
upper moon 4 but can't cut through or
shoot through its finger-sized neck
another clone comes from behind and it
looks like genya's neck which can't heal
back is about to get destroyed we
finally get a sort of life flashing
before his eyes slash flashback moment
where it's revealed that he was so angry
and wanted to become a hashera so badly
because he desperately wanted sanemi to
respect him we find out that genya's mom
was especially small and their father
was a big and terrible person he would
hit their mom and them and despite her
small size their mother would always try
to shield them from their father genya
was actually glad when his father was
stabbed and killed by a rival one day
saying he got what he deserved he viewed
his father like a monster and his mother
like a hero like with nezuko and tanjuro
genya and sanemi had younger siblings
that they looked after one unfortunate
day their demonized mom came back and
killed the younger siblings senemy was
the one who finally stopped her and
rather than thanking him for what must
have been a ridiculously difficult and
traumatizing thing to do kenya cried
hugged his mother's dead body and even
called sunemi a murderer later he would
realize that what he initially thought
was a wolf that attacked them was
actually his mother and that sun emmy
was only trying to protect him as a
result he felt very guilty all this time
and wanted to apologize to sunemi they
promised to protect their family
together but all genya did was blame
sunemi for doing the dirty work that had
to be done so now back to the present
genya is about to die regretting the
fact that he couldn't apologize or
protect sanami like sudamy always
protected him he thinks to himself that
he doesn't have any talent he can't use
breathing and he can't become a hashira
that's another interesting detail about
genye he was able to become this strong
and get this far despite being the
breathless demon slayer he wanted his
brother to acknowledge his strength but
all he remembers is sunami telling him
that scum like him can't be his brother
and that he wants genya to quit the
demonstr altogether tundra comes to the
rescue saves genya and motivates kenya
to try again and become a hashida but
genya touched by tundra's kindness and
no longer being the egoic angry dude he
usually was actually saves tundra by
blocking a strong enemy attack that
leaves genya's own body riddled with
lethal holes and he tells tundra that he
can't take the upper moon's head so
tundra will have to do it however tundra
doesn't succeed initially either and
zohaku 10 aka the hatred clone aka the
most powerful clone is summoned formed
by sekido's absorption of karaku aizetsu
and urugu luckily for genya tundra and
nazuko none of who are a match for the
wood jutsu using zohaku 10 at this point
mitsuri the love hashira shows up and
saves them it is at this point that
genya starts biting through the wood
that zohaku ten has used to trap nezuko
tanjo and himself tunjuro is shocked
when he sees this calling genji's teeth
incredibly strong the narrator then
tells us that by eating demon flesh
genya gains the physical constitution of
a demon if he eats a strong demon his
strength and regeneration increase
proportionally it's a very unique and
cool twist where genya has the potential
to get stronger in direct proportion to
the strength of the demon he's fighting
we're told that his eating demon stuff
was a last resort for genya because he
didn't have great physical ability and
wasn't able to use breathing it was his
last chance for gaining the power
necessary to become a hashida his
personal special abilities include
incredible jaw strength and special
digestive organs that make this
demonization possible he is the only one
in all the demon slayer core currently
with this talent after consuming some of
the wood jutsu genya becomes capable of
ripping a tree out of the ground and
throwing it at an enemy tundra for his
part is shocked by this display of
strength when he witnesses it kenya is
also strong enough to rip off the arms
of hantengu's giant resentment clone
when it appears we see that there is a
drawback to genji's demon power-ups when
we realize that nezuko's flames will
burn him too because of his partial
demon flesh so he has to retreat from
hantengu's burning body so tantra and
nezuko take over tundra ends up slicing
the real body's head but the price seems
very high indeed when it appears like
nezuko will burn in the sun luckily
nezuko becomes the first demon who can
withstand the sun at this point and
turns out to be fine tundra nesco hug
and witnessing this even the usually
angry genya can't help but crack a smile
now let's fast forward to the hashida
training arc where genya and sunemi have
another conversation like before senemy
tells genya that he doesn't have a
little brother and genyo should give up
he even says that if kenya doesn't knock
it off and quit playing at demon slayer
he'll straight up kill him he keeps
insulting him saying that someone who
can't even use breathing shouldn't call
himself a swordsman genya tries to
finally apologize but sademi says he
doesn't even care genya tries to defend
himself by saying he fought so hard and
even ate a demon but this only angers
sunami it appears like sanemy is about
to poke kenya's eyes out before tangero
rescues him tundra is angry that sanmi
just tried to kill his little brother
but sanemy says he'll just damage genya
beyond recovery unless he quests the
demonstrator core right away tundra
continues being the nice guy and points
out that if not for genya they would
have been defeated by the upper ranked
demon meaning hantengu as tundra spars
with an angry sun zenitsu helps get
genya out of there while remarking how
his older brother is crazy instead of
being grateful and understanding genya
punches zanitsu in the face saying don't
insult my big brother and all i can
think is oh man poor's 72 trying to do
someone a favor and getting punched in
the face now let's fast forward to
genya's most important fight the fight
against upper moon 1 kokushibo the
strongest upper moon kokushibo is a
whole other level of demon he's the
strongest demon after muzon and he was
originally a skilled demon slayer who
used arguably the second strongest form
of breathing after sun breathing namely
moon breathing his demonization
increased his powers and his moon
breathing was enhanced through his blood
demon art he's so strong that muichiro
one of the most talented hashira who
beat an upper moon by himself starts
shaking and senses that his body doesn't
want to fight for the first time in his
life after he takes out his blade and
uses moon breathing kokushibo
effortlessly cuts off muichiro's arm and
immobilizes him by pinning him to a beam
keep in mind he does this easily against
one of the most talented hashira who has
awakened his demon slayer mark which is
like going super saiyan for demon
slayers it is at this point that genya
appears in a matter of seconds kokoshibo
cuts off kenya's arms and then cuts his
body in two bisecting him kokoshibo can
tell immediately that genya is the one
who has been eating demons and even
mentions that over 300 years ago there
was another demonstrator like him
however with that demon slayer cutting
him in half killed him but genya is
still not dead just as kokushibo is
preparing to finish him off by cutting
off his head big bro sun emi comes in
and rescues his little brother at the
last second the fact that sanemy saved
him doesn't surprise genya though since
tanjuro previously told him that sun emi
despite superficial appearances doesn't
have the faintest whiff of hate for
genya and in fact loves him as much as
ever man the things tundra can smell
absolutely amazing finally sanmi
explains that he wanted genya to have a
house somewhere and raise a family and
grow old that's why he wanted him to
quit the demon slayer core he wanted
this happy peaceful future for genya and
he would have made sure a demon never
got near him and suddenly the feels
start rushing in for genya and us as we
all start to cry if you hated tsunami
before it's hard to keep doing so after
this moment suddenly goes on to occupy
kokoshibo until gyo made the strongest
hashida shows up then sanemi and gyome
start fighting kokoshibo together gyome
succeeds in breaking kokoshibo's sword
only for it to regenerate because it is
made of his demon flesh muichiro who is
going to die soon decides to join the
battle too but not before pushing
kenya's body back together so he can
regenerate and passing him some of
kokushibo's hair so genya can eat it
after consuming the hair genya gets a
huge boost and regenerates from being
bisected with incredible speed he also
starts to hear muzon's voice as well
while demonstrator mark sunemi gyome and
muichiro fight kokushibo genya remembers
tundra saying something very relevant to
this moment he said that the weakest
person has the greatest potential since
the opponent can only focus on a certain
number of fighters he focuses on the
stronger fighters and so there's an
opening for the weakest to catch him off
guard so in a way genya being the
weakest fighter present can actually
turn into a strength genny resolves to
do something and eats the piece of
kokushibo's sword that gyome broke off
so he can increase his power even more
genya then manifests a demonstra mark
similar to kokoshibo's he then recalls
the plan he and muichiro devised once
muichiro stops kokushibo kenya has to
shoot without hesitation now that the
time has come genya aims his gun which
is now surrounded by demon flesh and
kokoshibo looking eyes the implication
is that the gun and bullets might be
more accurate and more powerful now and
as he fires the demonized shotgun we see
that genya can now control his bullets
like living things despite the fact that
kukushibo deflected them they make their
way into his body then genya uses a
blood demon art where the bullets sprout
into trees engulfing and trapping
kokoshibo this could be a throwback to
upper moon 4's wood style jutsu which is
cool since it implies genjia can keep
and adapt blood demon arch from demons
he tasted long ago and combined
different blood demon arts together to
form unique attacks like this one
despite temporarily trapping kokoshibo
and sending him into a flashback
kokoshibo ends up sprouting blades from
all over his body the blades are
accompanied by air slashes that free him
from the roots and hurt the slayers
bisecting genya vertically this time
muichiro's blade turns red and sun
mangyome keep pressuring kokushibo so
kenya again though badly hurt sees this
as an opportunity to attack again
because there are still flesh bullets
inside kokushibo he makes another root
sprout from kokoshibo's body and
kokushibo realizes he can't use his
technique when he tries to the tree in
his back is sucking up his blood and
growing from it so as a result he's
probably lacking the blood necessary to
use his op blood demon art and his body
is also seizing up due to the intense
pain of muichiro's red blade the bullets
and red blade make it possible for gyome
to drop his nietrain spike ball on
kokoshibo's head then tsunemi comes in
to complete the four-member combo attack
and hits down on gyome's spiked ball
both weapons turn red like muichiro's
meaning they are super effective against
demons and kokushibo's head finally
comes off it seems like it's finally
over but kokoshibo actually starts
regenerating his head and if he
succeeded in doing so they would be
unable to kill him with nichiren weapons
the sun would be the only way to stop
him and since they're in a different
dimension without the sun he would be
invincible for all intents and purposes
fortunately for us the damage is great
enough and kokoshibo's internal shame at
what he's become is strong enough that
he ultimately vanishes as he's dying
genya asks gyome to place his body next
to sonomy he is glad he was able to help
sunomi and that his older brother
survived the battle sonomy wakes up
shocked to see his little brother's body
crumbling away like that of a demons
kenya finally goes all out with the
apologies for what he said after sunimi
killed their demonized mother and for
always causing trouble at this point the
ultimate bad boy sunmi is crying along
with genya begging him not to die it's
legit one of the saddest moments in the
series as genya disappears while telling
sunemi that he wants him to be happy
because his older brother is the nicest
person in the world who would have
thought that we'd ever view or anyone
would ever view the guy who ruthlessly
stabbed our precious nezuko in the
beginning as a nice guy and even if nice
is pushing it a bit you can't help but
feel for sonomy as he cries
uncontrollably struggling with the loss
of the most important person in this
world for him and what's even sadder is
that sunami doesn't even have time to
mourn as gyoume tells him to raise his
head this isn't over until they defeat
muzon but wow this was one of the best
fights in demonstrator and showed just
how powerful and useful genya could be
demonstrate as a series often focuses on
the importance of the demon slayers all
doing their part to defeat the
overpowered demon moons but still it's
worth mentioning that without genya they
would not have been able to win and both
gyome and sunemi would have died kenya
proved to be insanely powerful
especially when you consider the fact
that he couldn't even learn any breath
style his power to demonize after eating
demon flesh was interesting and pretty
op it allowed him to survive from
attacks that only demons would be able
to regenerate from like being cut in two
furthermore after eating kokoshibo's
flesh he could somehow combine all of
his powers to create a blood demon art
that allowed him to telepathically
control bullets and to have those
bullets then sprout into trees once
they've invaded the demon's body as if
that wasn't powerful enough the roots
would suck demon blood and thus take
away a demon's ability to use their
blood demon art effectively it should
also be noted that if genia didn't lose
his life in this fight he might have had
a chance to consume muzon's flesh or
even demon king tangier's flesh and who
knows how strong he might have become
then either way you can't deny that he
played an invaluable role in the fight
against one of the strongest demons
proving that he definitely had more than
what it takes to be a demon slayer and
perhaps even to be a hashira but let me
know what you think about this in the
comments would a telepathic tree bullets
genya be hashira level or would he at
least be able to become hashtag level
after absorbing some muslin flesh from
my perspective the argument can
definitely be made that telepathic tree
bullets genya would have performed
better than tangent uzui against upper
moon 6 dakian yutaro especially if we
consider his ability to take away blood
demon hearts but that is it for this one
the breathless demon slayer who arguably
earned the title of hashida level and
official hashrat or not played a crucial
role in beating the strongest upper moon
alongside three of the most talented
hashira in the game if you did enjoy
this video take a second now and make
sure to smash that like button let me
know and if this video hits 6500 likes i
repeat 6500 i'll get started on the next
house strongest video remember that
smashing that like button is your ichi
energy and passing is muzon energy so
choose wisely and let me know what
character you'd like to see covered for
the next video upper moon 1 upper moon 2
or another character that i've yet to
cover if you haven't yet and you love
demon slayer make this the video
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates that's
just the way it works and after you're
subscribed and you're just waiting for
your requested video to drop feel free
to check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos of all the demon moons all the
hashira at least 18 other how strong his
videos about demonstrated characters and
much more link to that is in the
description and i especially wanted to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord
twigo himself alpha sigma and other one
to your patrons the ones who stand on
top all clans ingrata al-jatal pate hepa
the red-haired fox hinokami and water
the toasted tree corey mcgowan the spike
dylan isadore spidey life chanel
tungsten targets big buddhist monkey d
quilly cody hebert and jeremy cummings
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
joanne garcia fat boy games kaido might
be a duck jessica rabbit and jeremy
phillips thank you all so much if you're
also a fan who enjoys our work you can
directly support more of it by going
over to patreon.com anime pro and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course the dank memes
so check out patreon.com anime upload
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button that
you've hopefully already destroyed so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you